I have uh I have a similarly like kind
of funny story uh that happened just the
other night
um so you know we just got back from uh
tour which we'll obviously talk about
later in the show yeah but um you know I
wanted to like catch up with some
friends because I haven't seen them in a
while right and we were doing a meet-up
uh in Syria and uh this is like you know
there's a couple of izakayas that me and
my group of friends like going to you
know just for a big group meet up
because it's you know it's especially
like on like a Friday night or whatever
most isakizen is in in should be yeah
yeah
especially now but I know of a couple of
like you know kind of hidden spots that
usually are quite free even on weekends
so we went there and you know we were
just like drinking chatting away and we
were the only ones there to begin with
right and we were like oh this is great
we got the whole place to ourselves
um and then just like I don't know maybe
two three hours into the night uh this
huge group of people just start walking
like I want to say like 50 to 100 people
Jesus just like all like you know yeah
like five people at a time and then it's
10 people and then it's five people and
then before you know it this entire
place is packed with just like standing
around drinking and stuff like that
um you know but it's like whatever we
got the we got our seats we're having
fun and it's all good yeah and then
about 20 minutes in I just kind of like
noticed I'm like man it's really quiet
why is it so quiet and I'm looking
around and it's still full of people but
it's like really quiet yeah almost to
the point where we're the only ones
talking and then in the corner of the
bar I see the sign in Japanese that says
buy yearly meet and drink Meetup for the
Deaf
oh and I noticed every single person in
this bar other than us is talking in
Sign Language oh wow and I'm like that's
why it's so quiet because literally no
one is talking and everyone is just
signing that's awesome and and it's so
bad but like the first thing in my mind
that I thought of was well I hope we're
not being too loud
that's the only thing you don't have to
worry about now but it's like
immediately like oh [ __ ] oh wait no we
good but it was really cool because it's
like you know I I knew a couple of
people in school who were like deaf and
stuff like that but like I'd never seen
that many deaf people in a social
setting like a little on a bar right and
everyone's like signing to each other
and there are people on like uh video
calls to each other and they're signing
to each other and I'm like this is
really freaking cool but it's also
really weird because it's so packed and
yet it's so quiet yeah and you all you
hear is just like the rustle of like
clothes moving around stuff if it's not
talking
um but so yeah that was a that was a
really interesting time I guess I guess
now you know if you come to Tokyo you go
to shibia there's a buy yearly meeting
for the deaf apparently so uh I like how
you got like the one day the buy the one
day the one day out of the two days yeah
where it's just a bunch of different
people who are like should we go
drinking yeah let's go drinking yeah it
was really cool yeah yeah I mean I've
been out like a like a bunch since
coming back to Japan and like I've
definitely noticed one one thing I've
noticed now is that before now that
because before phone everyone knew you
were living in the country right
everyone knew you were living in the
country because the borders were closed
but now that the borders are open I've
seen like a total mentality change right
because now now before when I go to a
restaurant everyone's like oh you know
where'd you live how long have you been
living here now people are like
panicking because they're like is it a
is it a tourist or is it yeah
Japanese they're speaking to me back in
English now
all right well that's a white guy yeah I
went I went to this restaurant the other
day with Sydney and they literally asked
us oh God uh are you visiting and we're
like no we live there and they're all
like oh it's a Japanese menu okay for
you because you know some places don't
have an English menu yeah we said yeah
we've lived here before Japanese menu is
fine
um so we go sit down they give us the
English menu anyway even though we said
a Japanese menu was okay they're like no
no no no no we don't trust you here's
the English I've had that having me so
many times like the waitress comes up to
me just like oh English is okay and I
reply back in Japanese you know being
like no no Japanese is fine yeah I live
around here and it's just like oh okay
comes back and she's like he's the
Englishman just in case I'm like
[ __ ] I just talked to you in
Japanese I'm good I can read it oh my
God yeah God knows there's so many more
foreigners now
we've literally landed in the airport
and we got recognized like instantly too
bad the guy was really nice shout out to
this guy getting our bags and this guy
goes I'm gonna bother you guys but I'm a
big fan yeah yeah thanks man appreciate
that yeah no just like I'm sure you you
two have noticed as well but just like
crazy yeah exponentially just more
people yeah I mean we did this uh I did
this IRL stream with Chris and Pete and
uh yeah it was uh insane we had so many
more stream snipers oh yeah it was
insane I did I did notice an interesting
thing though where at least with me uh I
immediately know if someone is a fan of
like the anime man or if someone is a
fan of trash taste yeah because I know
they're a fan of trash taste because
they come up to me and they go are you
Joey
but if they're a fan of me they go are
you the anime man and that's where I'm
like okay I know exactly like which mode
to switch to what to talk about and
stuff because I had that exact same
experience like maybe 10 minutes apart
like one day because my parents were
visiting
um and you know I got recognized a bunch
because I was out and about and yeah
just like 10 minutes apart there was one
dude who was like are you the anime man
never heard of trash days
10 minutes later American dude stops me
and goes yo Joey what's up man I just
missed out on the trash taste toy and
I'm like yeah it's it's just really
interesting kind of like the the dynamic
between like the I guess the two fan
bases if that makes sense
um but yeah I mean I mean I can tell as
well because it's like the gig up or the
guns you know how do they refer to me
yeah sometimes they just they just
mistake me for Joey which happens a lot
goes I love the other Asian guy in trash
taste I was like which one
I don't know
which one were you referring to are you
talking about the full Asian guy
all right I also like is that
disrespectful yeah I don't know but I
mean it's cool though because I felt
like a lot of the bars and restaurants
feels like they kind of returning to
normal almost yeah yeah it's like it's
like nice the world is healing there has
literally been like a switch I've
noticed that with like all these
restaurants and bars yeah yeah just a
show much more alive now yeah and so
much more like down for foreigners to
come in yeah yeah it's crazy how night
and day it's worked it's like they're
actually prepared you know for you know
for more foreigners to come in well
because I'm sure as a business owner
you're probably just like frothing for
the foreigners to come yeah I mean like
you know there's only so many times
some of them are probably just like oh
God here they come again but others are
just like oh thank God we can actually
get customers in now yeah you know not
have to rely on the same three local
people that come back every week right
yeah it's been nice my favorite thing
now is seeing all the tick tocks of like
this crazy thing I found in Japan it's
like a really it's a really like
well-documented tourist thing yeah yeah
I believe it it's like all right this is
the craziest this is the craziest Cafe
that I found in Shinjuku and it's like
all the same voice like it's it's like
sorry I'm not trying to be like talking
dirty it's just funny it's just funny I
I find it fun as well because I I get
recommended those tick tocks sometimes
as well where it's just like this is how
life in Japan works and it's like the
vending machines keep the [ __ ] drinks
cold I actually thought I saw that one
there's like eight amazing things that
made Japan so convenient yeah I remember
I saw one the other day which is like
this girl who clearly first time in
Japan and stuff like that and it was
like I want to take you guys to my
favorite local Ramen Shop that I think
is absolutely delicious it was a [ __ ]
eater
you can get this anyway literally anyone